- Hey, guys, #podSessions number four.
At this point, I'm not gonna do the whole
intro like I've done in the other three.
Hopefully if you've been listening along,
you've got the context of the show.
Bringing people together that
I'm interested in from afar.
Some I know really well, some
I'm just getting to know,
some I just am meeting for the first time.
I've really enjoyed it.
This format has been super interesting.
I think we're getting better and better
at mixing up the crew,
and I'll be really honest,
I apologize to the other three
sessions that started us off,
I think this is gonna be the best one yet.
- Lit.
- And so we are going to introduce.
We will start with ladies first.
Why don't you introduce yourself and give
a quick little line about
your jam, what you do,
and then we'll take it from there?
- I am Hannah Bronfman,
thanks so much for having me.
- [Gary] Of course, Hannah.
I run a wellness media
company called HBFIT.
I'm also a DJ, and I curate
and create content for myself,
my company, and a lot of
other companies as well.
- [Gary] Awesome.
- I'm Nik Stauskas,
professional basketball player
for the Brooklyn Nets.
I got traded here a couple months ago.
It's my fourth year in the league.
And I'm a huge fan of the
show, huge fan of Gary.
- [Gary] And we just had the
best one-on-one meeting ever.
- We did have a pretty
good one-on-one meeting.
Learned a lot.
- [Gary] Love it. My man.
- What's up, guys.
Illmind, I'm a music producer,
four-time Grammy-nominated.
- [Gary] Four-time?
- Yeah, I'm an official Grammy loser.
- I'm a five-time New York
Times bestselling author.
- Oh, they're not even
ready for that (laughs).
Worked with J. Cole, Kanye West,
Kendrick just dropped
that Black Panther album,
produced X with my man--
- Congrats.
- Thank you, with my man
Sounwave, shout to T--
- My wife asked me about
you being in it today.
- [Illmind] Nice.
- It's hit the lexicon.
- Aw, that's crazy.
Well, I did do Moana, You're Welcome,
Disney with Lin-Manuel.
I did some stuff with Lin and just kind of
happy to be here, man.
Gary Vee's the man.
- So this is a really fun format,
and the thing that I'm
starting all these shows with
has been really fun to explore.
I want to go back around
the circle and ask you
what you are currently obsessed with.
Now, a couple episodes ago,
the crew went really like,
"World peace" and like, very
vague, complete bullshit.
I mean, not bullshit,
maybe they are actually
passionate about world peace,
but I want something subtle, right?
Like this new marker you have
or your new teammate's haircut
or a new up and coming kid's song
or something outside your genre,
like you're obsessed with fixing
the pothole on your street.
What are you currently obsessed with?
Hannah?
- Okay, well, I mean, besides
multiple beauty products,
because that's a daily obsession.
I have something new
everyday, but really, though?
- Like, really, really.
- Really, really I'm
obsessed with this company
that I'm advising, and it's
like a crazy data company
that basically scrapes all
of your Instagram comments
and can tell the intent of
a user to buy something.
So, that's what I'm
obsessed with right now.
I kind of want to know, like
they could basically tell me
if I wanted to put out a product,
what product that would
be based on my audience.
- So you're all about the big data?
- I am, right now, I'm obsessed.
- Are you nerding out on it?
- I am, yeah.
- [Gary] Like you're just sitting there,
and be like, "Holy shit".
- Yeah, it's kind of incredible
because then you can also
start to tailor your own
content, and right, so--
- [Gary] You use it to like--
- Exactly.
- So, are we gonna see avocado
face masks from you (laughs)?
Like all sorts of random shit?
- It's funny you say that
because I've been thinking about
a new series called
Face Masks in the Wild,
where you're literally
putting on a face mask
and going out to do normal things.
- [Illmind] That's sick.
- You might actually see
me in an avocado face mask.
I should have worn one
today, to be honest.
(laughing)
- No, this is, your
regular face is better.
Alright, Nik.
- Something I'm currently
obsessed with, so I mean,
I guess being a professional
athlete, what I eat
and what I put in my body is important.
And there's this, I don't know,
maybe you guys have been
there, it's called Sweet Green?
- [Hannah] Yeah, love.
- I love Sweet Green.
- What is this, 1999 (laughs)?
- I don't know, I don't know how--
- Where are you from?
- Well, I just moved to
Brooklyn from Philly.
I'm from Toronto originally.
- [Gary] And is there no
Sweet Greens in Philly?
- There is a Sweet Green in
Philly, but I had no idea
that this is like, I thought
Sweet Green was just in Philly,
to be honest with you.
(laughing)
So over the last couple of months, I have,
I'm talking about every
day I have Sweet Green.
I have to--
- What's your favorite dressing?
- Balsamic, I have to have
the balsamic dressing.
- D-Rock is shaking his head.
- [D-Rock] I like lime cilantro.
- See for me, it's the cashew peanut, but.
- I haven't even tried that one.
I've heard it's really good though.
- Yeah, it's fire.
- With me, I'm one of
those guys that's like
once I find something that
works for me or that I like,
I don't try anything else, so like--
- Wait a minute, Nik, so what
were you eating before this?
Before you switched into this--
- You don't even remember.
What was life before Sweet Green?
- I was like, I can't even remember.
I honestly didn't have a go-to place.
- [Gary] You were lost.
- I was really lost.
- It wasn't Philly cheese steaks, right?
- Although, I did like
a Philly cheese steak
every now and then.
- Yeah, they're crazy.
- Those things are really good.
But too many of those,
and I'd be out the league.
- [Gary] Ill?
- Man, but aside from Star
Wars and Game of Thrones?
- [Gary] Yes (laughs), those are macro.
I wanna go really, really, really narrow.
- I'm actually, I've
just been getting into
and being obsessed with
different ways to compose music.
So you have the black and white key piano,
has been the main instrument for,
I mean, you know, you're a DJ.
So the piano's been our main instrument
for hundreds of years, if
not thousands of years.
So now with technology,
there's ways to trigger chord
progressions and different
melodies on your phone,
like being able to not play an instrument,
but be able to compose full melodies
with triggering on the phone.
And so, in doing my research,
I'm downloading all
these apps on my phone,
and there's actually these
new pieces of hardware
that allow for you to
compose full professional
pieces of music and access
gospel chord progressions
that you would need years
of training to access,
but now I can do it with
the push of a button.
So I just think that's interesting.
- That sounds like I can
get into the music industry.
- You can, no you literally can.
So I'm kind of obsessed
with being a music producer
and being trained in music,
but then also using that
technology to be able to--
- Not being fancy and romantic about it.
And instead of saying that's
bullshit and being sad
that you had all these
years, being open to it
and riding that wave.
- Yeah, and then also, too,
like where music is headed
because of that.
I mean, you can get a random
kid, download Free Loops
and be able to compose an
amazing piece of music.
I mean, how's that gonna
shake up the production world?
- It's gonna change the supply
and demand of opportunity.
I mean, it's just the
same old game, right?
The Internet is the middle man.
Technology squeezes the middle.
And we're in it now.
- I think the next thing is holograms.
Putting the glasses on and
then composing in the air.
- Oh, whoa, that's crazy.
Kind of like an augmented?
- Exactly.
Like imagine ProTools, but
like moving the waves around.
- Totally, it's like very Minority Report.
- [Illmind] Yeah, Minority Report.
Yeah, it's crazy.
- [Hannah] Yeah, that was just a little--
- [Gary] Just do it one more time?
- Yeah, that was just (laughs).
- I actually think that
technology and holograms and VR,
that we will never get to the place
where we're really
wearing glasses at scale,
that by the time the
technology gets good enough,
that we're all deep into that world,
we'll be into contact lenses.
- Do you think that's in our lifetime?
- [Gary] 100%.
- I think so.
I think the next big one is in-ear,
and then the one after
that will be in-eye.
- I think in-ear is gonna be a lot of fun
because it eliminates language.
I love the fact that I'll be
able to go in mainland China
or India and we're just
talking to each other
because it's translating for
me in my native language.
- Yeah, that's sick.
- But here's my question.
I'm all about that--
- Real quick, Hannah, I apologize.
So if you're in seventh grade
Spanish, fucking mail it in,
it's not gonna fucking matter.
(laughing)
- But that's what I mean.
Okay, so because, right,
because that this technology
is coming and that it will
break down so many barriers,
do you think that learning
other languages will become obsolete?
- It will be commoditized.
So it's not that it's obsolete
and you're more than welcome,
but yes, it is not as valuable as it was
in the same way that it's
not as valuable today
to memorize who the presidents
of the United States were
because we have a phone on
us and we can look it up.
- But you still have to do that in school.
- Yeah, but school's broken
for the reality of the marketplace.
- But will school be
fixed by the time that--
- Probably not, my intuit--
- [Hannah] Right, which
then creates the problem.
- Well, the problem exists now, actually.
Broken school is causing real problems
because people are sitting
with enormous college debt
and they don't have leverage
to close the gap on that debt
post-school, and they
aren't being taught skills
that matter as much in
today's environment.
When you are going into a
job in the corporate world,
I mean, listen, college
was a great machine
for a 1950s, 60s, 70s, 80s, 90s world.
And it hit its apex, but it's
now clearly on the decline.
And, no, I am unbelievably
down on the education system
that is in place right now to an extreme.
To an extreme.
And so, let's talk about
music for a minute.
Emerging artists,
obviously, you know I have
a lot of passion for
that, Boyd's in the room.
That's been our jam for 10 years.
I know you fuck with a lot of people,
so it's hard, I'm putting
you on a tougher spot
where I know there's
31 kids that you think
really have real potential.
But for fun and it just is what it is,
it's not like you're not
naming somebody else.
If I put you in a corner, which I am,
who's an emerging artist
that most people won't know
that you're like, "Wow, if I had a bet,
"and I'll be really happy in four years
"when Iris sends me the clip of this,
"and I was super right about this person."
Who's that kid right now?
- Oh wow, oh man.
There's a handful.
- [Gary] I know there's a ton.
- I'm trying to narrow it down in my mind.
- While you're doing that,
I'm gonna let you really think about this.
I'm gonna ask Nik, who's gonna--
- [Illmind] I got it, though, I got it.
- Oh, you got it?
- I got it, yeah.
This girl G.L.A.M.
- [Gary] Glam.
- G-L-A-M, it stands for
Good Lyrics and Music.
And so she's from
(laughing), yeah, G.L.A.M.
She's from Oakland.
She lives in New York.
She raps, she sings, she
produces all of her own music.
I dibble and dabble, you know I'm good.
But she does all her shit.
And she's kind of, if I can
kind of describe her sound,
she's Missy meets, I
know this is bold, but--
- Yeah, no, this is what always happens.
- It's like Missy fun, but Oakland,
very like Oakland-sounding.
- Like Missy meets Too Short?
- Yeah, you can say that.
Yeah, like very, like it's
Bay, but it's soulful and fun
and upbeat, but she got bars, too.
She could rap.
She's fucking amazing.
- Is she SoundCloud or is she Spotify?
- She's both.
She's both, but she doesn't
have that much new stuff out.
- [Gary] Well, that's good.
- But she's cooking, man.
She's amazing, G.L.A.M.
- [Hannah] Alright, I'm
gonna look into that.
- Yeah, look her up.
- Nik, who's gonna win the
NCAA tournament this year?
Obviously, you had a really
fun career at Michigan.
Who's gonna win this
year's NCAA March Madness?
It's coming, it's gonna
be here any minute.
- Yeah, I mean, once it
comes to the tournament,
your guess is as good as mine.
I mean, anything really
happens in a tournament.
Like last year, that's actually crazy.
My alma mater, Michigan, they
were bottom of the Big 10
throughout the entire season.
- [Gary] Yep, they got hot.
- They went to the Big 10 tournament,
and they are taking off
the runway on the plane
to go to the Big 10 tournament,
and their plane crashed.
And when their plane crashed,
everyone got off the plane.
Really traumatic experience.
And coach looked at them and was like,
"Do you guys still want to go?
"We can call off the season right now.
"We can forfeit and the season's done."
And the players were like, "We're going."
They win the big, they end
up going as a bottom seed.
They win the Big 10 tournament.
Get a seed in the NCAA tournament.
And then make it to the Sweet 16.
So, there's really no telling.
If I had to guess, I'd say--
- You really don't want to
say Michigan State, right?
- Michigan State has no chance (laughing).
There's no chance.
If I had to guess--
- Guys, for everybody listening,
Michigan State has a huge chance.
He's just a huge rival to this.
- If I had to guess,
I'm gonna go with Duke.
This kid Marvin Bagley at
Duke, he's gonna be a problem.
So if I had to guess,
I'm gonna go with Duke.
If not, I'm just gonna go with Michigan
and hope they make a run this year.
- Hannah, what is your favorite restaurant
and or actual meal right now?
Could be fast casual, what have you,
but what food are you
really thinking about?
And I'd love to know restaurant,
if there has been one in
the last six months or so.
- Interesting, well, there's a few.
I mean, okay, 4 Charles
has the best burger
in the city right now,
and it's the atmosphere,
the burger, everything about
it is hands-down, is amazing.
- What's it called?
- [Hannah] 4 Charles.
- Like 4, the number 4?
- [Hannah] Yeah, and it's got--
- Write it down, she wrote
for your music person.
She said, oh you're
streaming, so no worries.
- And then I've been dying--
- Have you been there, Tyler?
- [Tyler] Nope.
- Can you set up one of my
meetings there right now?
Can you actually, while
we're doing this podcast,
edit a meeting I'm
having in a couple weeks.
Send the invite, re-set it.
- It's hard to get a reservation.
So Monday night might be
ambitious, but maybe for you Gary
they'll make it happen, I don't know.
- Let's change this.
Let's buy 4 Charles company.
(laughing)
Nah, I'm kidding, I'm kidding.
We play it humble.
I'll go in six months,
I don't give a fuck.
- There's another place
called Nur, that I'm--
- What's the hardest place to
get into the city right now?
- 4 Charles has a really crazy--
- Really?
Who else?
Anybody else?
It's so cool to hang out with cool people.
This is how I get the information.
- Nur is really hard
to get into right now.
- So both your answers
happen to be also super hard.
- Listen, I mean, when
you're talking about--
- [Gary] You're not providing
for the people, Hannah.
- I think, to be honest,
I cook at home mostly
because I love to cook.
- [Gary] You love cooking?
- Yeah, it's a very
therapeutic thing for me,
and I also care a lot
about what I put in my body
and whatnot, even though
I just said that the best
place to go is for a burger,
but it is one of those burgers
that you kind of just have to try.
- [Gary] How new is it?
- It's probably like six months old?
- Who's place?
- [Tyler] Trowdy goes every other week.
- Trowdy goes every other week?
Is Trowdy here?
- [Tyler] No.
- He never fucking works (laughing).
- I know a guy who has
a standing reservation
every Tuesday night,
and he's always trying
to get rid of them because
he can't go every week.
So, maybe I can throw
you one or something.
- [Gary] Please.
(laughing)
- And then there's this
other place called Nur,
which is like a new Israeli
place that opened up
that's supposed to be crazy.
- [Gary] Where is it?
- It's in Flatiron.
And I haven't been there yet, but it's--
- [Gary] You're dying to go?
- I'm dying to go, yeah.
- Love it.
What do you want to know?
What's on your mind?
What can I answer?
What can one of the
two, three of us answer?
Illmind, what's on your mind?
- Man, I wanna know if
it really is worth it
to, I mean you talk about
this shit all the time,
put yourself all in on something.
Is it really worth it to
go all in, in my world,
on the social media thing?
So go all in on YouTube, go
all in on all the platforms?
- Yes, yes, yes.
Let me tell you why.
- [Illmind] And just commit?
- Yes, let me tell you why.
It is grossly under-priced attention.
And it gives you the leverage.
- I mean, I agree.
I just came from a--
- [Gary] I know you
agree, you're living it.
- Yeah, I just came from a movie, I mean,
I just came from a meeting with YouTube.
And I took a deep dive into--
- Was it with Ben Mason?
- [Hannah] Yeah, it was.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, he's dope.
- I had the same meeting
yesterday with him.
What'd he tell you, though?
- I mean, he told me so many things.
Well, specifically, my YouTube channel's
for my company, HBFIT, so
we basically went straight
into what's working, what's not working,
where we can tailor, how we can optimize.
- My manager's calling me, sorry bro.
- [Hannah] No, it's all good.
- No, he's out.
(laughing)
- [Gary] Hannah, you're in, manager's out.
- But you know, at
first, I was like, damn.
There's a lot of shit I
need to be implementing
and doing differently, but I'm really glad
that I put out the content that I put out
so I have stuff to at least go off of
and know what to change and where to tweak
and do all that stuff.
It kind of seemed a little
overwhelming at first,
but I also have some girl
who is awesome and at school
wanted to use HBFIT as a
case study, so I have her
implementing all the findings.
- [Illmind] Sick.
- More importantly, to that point, Hannah,
guys, this is financially
viable to do the right thing.
Meaning, if you're in a place
where you could afford it, do it.
I don't know if you, I have 17 people,
and I'm about to go, I mean,
I just upped my Instagram ad
spend by a multiple of 12.
This is real.
This is a moment in time.
This is why we're crushing it.
I didn't write it just to write it.
I wrote it because I'm like, fuck,
the thing I believed nine years ago,
which I ended up being very right about,
I'm actually still underestimating it.
This is so fucking huge.
- Yeah, I think for me I just want
to make sure I am going all in.
I mean, when we had our first meeting,
you put the fucking battery in my back.
- I mean, I looked at your social.
- [Illmind] And then I
just went into my YouTube,
and I have to do YouTube.
- Let's talk about this real quick.
I saw that, we had that
meeting in the car.
And I literally watched
you go do the right thing
by YouTube, Instagram, making the memes.
I'm watching, I'm like,
he's fucking doing it.
What has happened?
- [Illmind] Extreme growth.
- Well, what the, and what about
outside of followers and things like that?
Like what about in real life?
- I mean, extreme growth, colleagues,
people that I was cool
with, now stepping in
and wanting to do more because
they're seeing more of it.
And then they're just seeing
the audience grow authentically.
- Right, so growth,
opportunity, more awareness.
I mean, honestly, I've been
looking at your page, too,
and I think that what you do
is, like not a lot of people
in the producing and
the music-making world
put out content the way
that you've packaged it.
- Not one, I'm trying to get
these motherfuckers to like,
you know, let's do this together
because my community
is super undereducated.
- Right, and you can be as
inclusive as you wanna be.
- [Illmind] I wanna try to help them.
- Right, no, no, no, I think it's--
- This is literally the story of my life.
It started with wine in 2006.
- [Illmind] Yeah, you were the guy.
- It was 2006, and I
believed in this shit.
It was YouTube, nobody
had ever heard of it.
It was five months old.
There wasn't a video that had
a million views yet, ever.
And it was really a different
world when I started.
And nobody knew anything
about wine that was under 35.
And it was just, I wanted to educate.
I wanted people to try new shit.
I was tired of people drinking
the same 15 kinds of wines
when there was like 4,000
kinds of wines worth drinking.
And then it happened with just
entrepreneurship in general.
There's a lot more people
that do the kind of thing
that I do on Instagram every
day, but to your point,
when a producer, music producer, does it.
I think the athlete journey, Nik,
to be honest with you, just like,
bro, you said to me,
in the meeting earlier,
"Yeah, okay, so I'm in
the gym for two hours."
I was just laughing.
People think they want
to be basketball players.
You're in the gym for two hours every day.
And that's just with the ball.
Then you go work out.
I don't think people understand.
That's what I told you earlier.
And I just had these kids in here
when I drew all over my table.
From 20 to 30, I did nothing.
I went all in.
No out, no out, no out, no out.
No burger place, no club, none of that.
All my friends, I'm 42, all my friends now
who are the same age, they're like,
"Remember?"
And I'm just like, no.
(laughing)
I don't even know what
club you're talking.
No, I never went to Suede.
No, I don't know it.
I don't know Tunnel.
I don't know it, I fucking worked.
And so to me, that's not, by
the way, the right answer,
it's just you need to know
what the cost of your ambition is.
So I could have been less
successful professionally,
and had some balance and fun, that's fine.
I could have.
It's just not what I want.
And you have to understand what you want
and what you're trying to achieve.
But yes, all in, every fucking
person listening to this.
And if you're listening to me,
you're already in the
consideration set of debating,
should I go all in?
If you even know who I am,
if you're even listening
to this right now,
the answer is yes because
if I, 22 months ago,
needed to remind my own
self, I need to go all in,
everybody needs reminding.
- [Illmind] True.
- What do you want to know Nik?
I mean, obviously you
and I had our one-on-one,
so what about more generally
or from the peeps here?
What kind of music do you listen to?
You got two fucking--
- I'm a hip-hop fan.
- Yeah, we were chatting up a lot.
- Yeah, we were just chatting.
For me, my favorite artist
right now is Travis Scott.
I feel like over the last two years,
everything Travis Scott
has made has just been--
- Turned to gold.
- Absolutely fire, like turned into gold.
So, definitely been a
huge Travis Scott fan.
Being from Toronto, I love Drake, and--
- What about KILLY?
- KILLY?
- From Toronto, right?
- [Nik] I don't know about KILLY.
- I don't know KILLY either.
- I don't know KILLY.
- Toronto has so many crazy up-and-comers.
- Canada has everyone, I mean it's crazy.
- [Gary] Go ahead, Mike,
I see why you wanna talk.
- [Mike] Yeah, you'll like KILLY.
- [Nik] KILLY?
- [Mike] Yeah.
- [Nik] How do you--
- K-I-L-L-Y.
- [Nik] K-I-L-L-Y?
He's a rapper?
- You're gonna love him.
- [Nik] Okay, I'll take your word for it.
- Oh, KILLY's on fire.
I mean, he's huge, bro.
- [Gary] He's huge to
somebody like Mike Boyd--
- Well, he's huge to people who
are looking for new artists.
- Exactly, by the way, this is what's so--
- [Mike] A record label
is trying to sign him--
- But, by the way, this is
what's so great about the game.
KILLY's huge for people that
look at the world that way.
This is burger place is huge for,
it's just what world are you in?
- [Illmind] Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- And that's why, by the
way, that's why, this show,
even the way it's flowing right now,
I'm like in the show, but then
my other part of my brain's
like analyzing the show.
I'm like, this is exactly right.
These are people that are in their world.
They know their worlds.
They're passionate about their worlds.
You know five guys right
now who are gonna be
the biggest basketball players
in the world in six years
that nobody else in this room
besides me has ever heard of.
Because they're either a
McDonald's All-American
or they're freshmen at Oklahoma right now,
but they don't live in that world.
But for you, you're like, "What
do you mean you don't know?"
- [Mike] You might be huge to KILLY.
You know what I mean?
He might look up to you
with you being from Toronto.
- Yeah, I mean the crazy
thing is with music for me
is that I guess I don't
really search for the next up,
I don't go on YouTube and
like, who's hot up-and-coming.
I'm more of like, what's--
- You're like, "Yo, did you
guys hear about The Weeknd?"
(laughing)
- Yeah, whatever's popular,
whatever is being put out there.
- By the way, I'm very similar to that.
I'm very similar to that when
I'm not in Mike Boyd mode.
Once every three or four
years, I'll go into his world,
and I'll get really in it,
which is what I'm in right now,
and then other times, I'm
super thrilled to just
give me the seven songs
that are most popular,
and I need a little
Lionel Richie, normally,
mixed in there as well
(laughing), and then I'm good.
Actually I want Lionel
on Monday to Monday.
- [Hannah] Do you listen to Hype Machine?
- No.
- Hype Machine is a good,
if I always just like,
if I'm in my office, I
just put that on Popular,
and that's how I find all my new music
because I constantly am DJ-ing,
and sometimes I DJ an
event where they're like,
"We'd actually like you to
play songs with no lyrics."
And I'm like, okay.
And then other times
it's like, the turn-up.
- I should send you a
bunch of instrumentals.
- Yeah, let me know.
I would love that, I would love that.
- [Gary] That's the best
thing that happened.
- Are you part of Record Pools, too?
Do they feed you the new
stuff, being a DJ, or?
- No, no.
I mean, I've got a lot of
friends who are producers
and I get a bunch of stuff from them.
There's also this kid,
have you heard of Buddy?
- Yeah, signed to Pharrell?
- [Hannah] Yeah.
- Yeah, he's ill.
- Buddy's sick, so he actually
performed at my wedding.
- [Illmind] Nice.
- It was the first time he
ever left the country, as well.
He's a kid from Compton.
And he got his passport just
for the wedding, too, yeah.
It was awesome.
- Buddy's the man.
You're right though about
there's different worlds
that are huge, and if you're not in them,
you don't know about them.
- Well, I mean, I think
that's, you know honestly,
that's in a weird way the
purpose of this format for me,
which is, somebody who's
consuming on the other end
is getting bounced
around to four different,
three different, two
different kind of worlds,
and I think that's super interesting.
And I think in a lot of ways,
curation has always been
unbelievably important and gets compounded
when there's a lot of supply.
And so for me, the only
reason I produce content
is to bring value to the
audience, period, end of story,
simple zero, zero, zero sum game.
And so I'm always challenging myself
to be better and better and better.
I want to be all-time.
I want to be all-fucking-time.
And so this format, for me, is incredible
because that's what's being
provided right now, right?
Like if you're on the other side of this,
you've literally just
found three new this,
two new that, one new that.
And obviously these shows are taking
very different forms every time.
What do you want to know, Hannah?
- What do I wanna know?
I guess right now what I'm
really interested in is
I'm kind of in a space where
I want to grow my brand.
I don't want to necessarily
have to physically
show up places to make money,
which obviously kind of then
translates into product.
When I think about product,
obviously marketing is a huge
part of that, and I just
wonder, for me, I really find
that I connect with products
that have integrity,
and their marketing ends
up being kind of shitty
because they've cared so much
about the integrity of the product.
- They're being too fancy and romantic.
- Right, but then all the
brands that are doing really,
really well are brands that
are actually the product
is shit, but the marketing is so on point.
- But I think the thing
to think about there
that you may want to debate is just
the game of how long a game is, right?
So, I think one thing that
people have to be thoughtful of
is a shitty product, over
the long term, will lose.
It will.
- I think that as well.
- So, one has to remember,
that you may deem Dove soap
or Coca-Cola or cereal,
Cinnamon Toast Crunch,
or Head and Shoulders as
shitty, but you've got
to reverse engineer the
context of the market, right?
So I think about music like
this all the time, too,
since we're staying on that theme,
or like sports, what I love
about sports is, guess what,
the shit's gonna play out on the court,
right in front of your fucking face.
There is gonna be no debate.
There's no, you can't talk trash.
And then you play.
And then it plays out.
You can be mad that a song
is number one on the charts
and you're like that's
some bullshit, bullshit.
Guess what, the market fucking spoke.
(laughing)
And so, that's how I
think about products, too,
as a lot of people that
have your profile and taste,
and that's the truth, are
getting into the product game,
I'm speaking to a lot of
them, and they're having this
interesting point of view,
this filter, makes sense.
I think what's interesting
in this conversation
is I've blindly accepted the market,
and then try to figure out
what I want to do within it.
- So, I'm kind of doing that as well.
I think also, and actually,
I feel like you kind of know my brand.
What would you think that
the product would be?
- [Gary] To make for you?
- Yeah.
- I've got a, I actually do
have a pretty good idea on this
because obviously we
haven't had the chance
to really chop it up, so it's like years
in the pent-up making.
I think you have permission
that a lot of people don't
to go completely left fucking field.
If you and I, let's say this
went, and we got friendly,
and you're like, "Gary, I really wanna
"do a business with you."
(sneezing)
Bless you, Boyd.
And you said, "I really
wanna do business with you."
And I'd be like, okay, only
under one circumstance.
We have to go to some weird fucking place,
bring in some product
nobody in America knows,
and it has to be legit shit, right?
Somebody figured, like pomegranates.
I was born in Russia, in
Belarus, specifically.
When I came to America,
pomegranates were huge
in the Soviet Union.
When we came to America, my mom
would go to different stores
to seek them out, and we would
have pomegranates in 1984,
1987, 1990, and my American
friends would come over
in those years, and be
like, "The fuck is that?"
(laughing)
They'd never seen a pomegranate
in their life, right?
And so like a lot of
people who are listening
who come from cultural backgrounds,
like if you've got a friend from Haiti.
They got some fucking
food that's in the store,
it's usually a cultural store,
you're like, "What is that?"
"What is that?"
I think what's super fascinating
about your positioning,
in my opinion from afar,
is you have permission to,
like we should go to Peru,
and find some random shit,
and make--
- It's the next anti-aging whatever.
- $100,000 fucking, you can
settle into the easy part
of making another uh, you
have upside to be like,
there's red bananas in
the fucking Amazon jungle,
and we're making fucking lip cleaner.
You should make some fucking
shit up that is true, though,
which is like the indigenous people
have been using this for 800 years.
That is a remarkable opportunity for you
that an enormous amount
of people do not have
because there's not a credibility,
a momentum, a star factor.
You need to be really thoughtful
because you have to understand why.
If I'm right, and the
product's rad, and it hits,
the economics are disproportionately crazy
because you have such a lead
and an ownership over a category,
not you're just a good
product within a category.
You're creating a fucking category.
- Interesting.
- [Illmind] I agree with that.
That's sick.
- Got a little NBA'd in here.
So that's where I'm at with that.
- [Hannah] Cool, I'm glad I asked that.
- Nik who's your favorite
athlete growing up?
- My favorite athlete?
- [Gary] Yes, sir.
- LeBron James, without a doubt.
- [Gary] Really?
- Yeah.
- [Gary] All you young fuckers (laughs).
- I was a huge--
- How old are you?
- 24.
- Oh wow.
- I was a huge LeBron fan.
First time I watched
him play was in Toronto.
I was 11 years old.
He was kind of just starting
out his career at that point.
And the first time he walked
out of the tunnel, I cried.
I cried when I saw him in person.
And then by the time--
- How did your dad or mom or
friend react to your crying?
- They, I mean, they just
knew I was obsessed with him.
So they were like, "That's
just Nik being Nik."
You know what I mean?
They didn't think anything of it.
But, my obsession got to
the point where every year
my Christmas present
was a trip to Cleveland
to watch the Cavs play.
- So what happened the first
your team, so your rookie year,
tell me the full story, go.
Your rookie year, tell everybody
who you were drafted by.
- I was drafted eighth overall
by the Sacramento Kings in 2014.
And so I'm playing for the
Kings, we're in Cleveland,
and the whole day leading up to the game,
my stomach's just in knots.
My first year, every game was
exciting because every night
I was going up against someone
that I had looked up to
as a kid, but LeBron was
a different story for me.
And so the game starts--
- Did you cry when you (laughs)?
- No, I didn't cry.
I didn't cry this time.
I didn't cry.
But the game starts and LeBron and I are,
like we play different positions,
so we weren't guarding each other.
But then maybe a minute and
a half, two minutes into
when I checked into the
game, it just happened
that in transition
there was a missed shot.
We came down on offense,
he matched up with me,
and he called it out, too.
He says, "I got Stauskas," and I was like,
did anyone else hear that?
He knows who I am.
(laughing)
He just said my name.
And for the whole possession,
I didn't even touch the ball,
he was just right next to me,
and I was just looking around.
I was like, does everybody see this?
LeBron's guarding me right now.
- That's awesome.
- [Illmind] That must have felt surreal.
- For me, that was like--
- Illmind, did you have something
like that in the studio?
Have you ever had that happen?
- [Illmind] Yeah, always man, always.
- No, but I get it, there's
a lot of people you--
- [Illmind] Oh, a specific one?
- Yeah, something like that
because obviously he had other
players he appreciated and
had stories, but I mean like
for real, for real.
- First time I met Dre, Dr. Dre.
I mean, Dre was--
- [Gary] Give me the story.
- The guy.
Okay, so, 2013 I'm in LA.
And I'm at this studio in LA.
And I get a call from
my guy who, at the time,
just got hired to be in A&R at Aftermath.
And so I knew him from years ago
when he was doing some other stuff.
And so he's like, "Yo,
Ill, what are you doing?"
I'm like, yo, I'm in LA.
I'm in the studio.
He's like, "Yo, I'm out here.
"I'm with Dre.
"Where you at?"
And I give him the address
to the studio, and he's like,
"Yo, me and Dre are across
the street at the bar."
So I'm like, Dr. Dre?
(laughing)
He's like, "Yeah, me
and Doc are over here."
He's like, "Yo, come
through, come say what's up."
So I leave the studio,
and I go into the bar,
and I see my man and Dre, Tahim.
And I meet Dre for the first
time, I'm like super stoked.
He's like, "Yo, Illmind, what's up, man?
"Yo, my man Tahim told
me you got that fire."
I'm like, yeah, you know,
I'm alright (laughs).
I do dabble a little bit.
And so we're having drinks.
He's buying me a shot.
And he's looking at me, like,
"Yo, Illmind, can't wait
to hear these joints."
I'm like, yeah, you know, we'll get in.
We'll get in.
And he's like, "You got a studio?"
I'm like, yeah.
And so, I'm like, yeah,
come across the street.
I'm actually in a session.
I have the room.
So then we leave the
bar, so it's me, Dr. Dre,
and my man, Tahim, and
so we go into the studio.
- [Gary] And you're thinking
what as you're walking in?
- I'm like, I'm 50% super
confident and stoked
because I love my shit and
I can't wait to show him.
And then 50% nervous as
fuck, like, oh my God.
I'm about to play my stuff for Dr. Dre.
And so he's sitting back there.
I'm on the board, speakers.
And then I plug my computer in.
And I start hitting play on some beats,
like a minute per beat,
just playing beats.
And I'm not looking back
because I'm super nervous.
I'm like, in my mind, Dre is doing this.
Like he's wildin' out in the back.
And so I'm looking straight,
and I'm just playing all my beats.
I'm like, yeah, I know
Dre fucks with this.
I know he loves this,
I know he loves this.
And then so a couple beats
in, I glance to the back.
And Dre is looking down
on his phone like this.
Super bored, not feeling anything.
And I was just like, damn.
My heart broke, and I was like, fuck.
So anyway, I stop playing it.
And then I had a convo with Dre.
He's like, "You know,"
he's like, "Your shit is cool,
"but it ain't really nothing
I haven't heard before."
And then we got into a
really deep conversation.
He was schooling me on stuff.
And then that was that.
And then a year later, I come back to LA.
And then he's working
on an actual project,
and then we start working together.
And he's showing me, this
is when the NWA movie,
before it dropped, he was
showing me trailers of the movie
and I'm super stoked.
Dr. Dre is showing me
clips of the new NWA movie
that no one has seen yet.
So then we get in the studio again.
He's like, "Yo, Illmind,
play me some stuff."
And he loved everything.
And he was like, "Yo."
And he recorded some
shit, and then from there
we just started a working relationship.
- That's amazing.
- So my first experience was terrible,
but then because I just kept
going and kept at it, I got.
And now, every time I see
Dre, it's super amazing,
but I still get super nervous around him
because it's always gonna be Dre.
- You got one, you said.
- Yeah, I had one, a
had a moment this week,
which was this week.
- This week you had your
core, like again, remember,
these guys have met other people,
but you're saying this is the one?
Happened this week?
- Dude, it happened this week, literally.
I had a shot of tequila with Oprah.
- No!
- [Gary] Wow.
- [Illmind] Airhorn.
- Literally, right?
I mean that was, listen, Oprah--
- You had a shot of
tequila with Oprah Winfrey?
Not Oprah Thompson.
- No, no, no Oprah Winfrey.
By the way, in Harlem, okay?
It doesn't really get better than that.
- Wait, was that at Red Rooster?
- It was not at Red
Rooster, it was at this--
- I love him, man.
I love that place.
Marcus, big shout-out.
Guys, if you ever come to New York
and you need to go to Red Rooster.
It's in Harlem, the flavor's legit.
It's just a good experience.
But go ahead.
- Okay, so the Studio Museum in Harlem
is an iconic museum here in New York City.
My mom has done tons of work
for them over the years.
I actually, it was a
full circle situation.
So I'd been going there ever since
I was in my mom's snuggly pack.
And I got a call, two weeks
ago, asking if I could DJ
the OWN Network event
at the Studio Museum,
which will be the last event
that will ever take place
in the Studio Museum because
they are closing that building,
tearing it down, and building a new one.
- That is not true.
I'm gonna run there
now and put on an event
because I wanna be the last event.
I'm just kidding (laughing).
- No, I already did it.
I already did it.
So I go and I'm like, okay, Mom,
you gotta come to the event.
This is crazy.
I didn't even think
Oprah was gonna be there,
you know what I mean?
I just thought I'm like
DJ-ing a corporate,
another corporate event, and
this time it was gonna be
uptown, full of black people,
so it was gonna be fun.
(laughing)
So I'm like, I'm down.
So I go and Oprah's there.
And next thing you know,
I'm on a second level,
so I'm like, oh, I'm probably not gonna
get to meet her or anything.
Next thing you know, after
she gives her speech,
she comes upstairs,
introduced herself to me,
and everyone in the whole place
is gonna take a shot of tequila.
And she hands me her shot,
then gets another one,
cheers me, says her whole
thing, we took a shot together.
I mean, granted, it
was also with the other
hundred people in the room, but we were
right next to each other, and
she handed me her tequila.
It was a major moment.
It felt, and also, it's Oprah.
I aspire to have so many of her qualities
and make an impact on
the world like she has.
And it was just epic.
- That's fucking awesome.
Good for you.
- [Hannah] Thanks.
- What is your first Instagram post?
I want you to pull up
your phone right now.
- [Illmind] How do I do that?
- What?
- How do I pull?
- [Gary] We're gonna teach you.
- Okay.
- [Gary] Stop your fucking stream.
- Okay, sorry guys.
- [Gary] Hit the fucking Instagram logo.
- [Illmind] We out.
- Let's go Nik, I wanna see it.
I'm gonna explain it visually.
You're just gonna keep
scrolling, scrolling, scrolling.
I think it's a fun thing--
- It's so funny, I remember
mine like it was yesterday.
- [Illind] You do?
- Yeah.
- [Gary] Alright, pull it up, pull it up.
- Wait so, I have to manually scroll?
Just fucking go.
- Actually, Instagram,
if you're listening,
Ishmon is Instagram, if
you're listening right now,
we'd like to you add a
button that allows you
to go directly to your first.
Yeah, it takes a while,
and you know how it does the whole thing.
- [Hannah] This is gonna take forever.
- Yeah, yeah, no, it's
gonna take you forever.
I know, we're gonna keep doing it.
- Well, I can just describe it.
- No, no, I want to really look at it.
- [Nik] I'm almost embarrassed.
I don't even know what's gonna come up.
- Well, this is a very fun thing.
This is a new game we've
just created on the spot.
What is your first Instagram photo ever?
I see Tyler Schmidt is doing it.
Anikon, the legend, is
here, but he's not doing it.
He's too fucking fresh to do it.
But I wanna see what everybody's
first Instagram photo is
and, as a matter of fact,
for everybody listening,
I'm gonna do a contest.
I'm gonna send somebody
five signed books, five.
This is where you can sell them
for 20 bucks on eBay and make some cash.
To one person randomly, go to your phone,
go to your profile, go to your
first Instagram photo ever,
screenshot your phone, Tweet
it at me, and put #GVfirst.
Yeah, #GVfirst, that'll be fine.
I'll find it.
And I'm gonna pick one of you.
- [Hannah] GVfirstIG.
- Okay, fine, thanks HB, #GVfirstIG
because we're collaborating here.
And I will pick one of you.
You found it Nik?
- Found it.
- [Gary] Nik, let's see it.
- You probably haven't
posted that many, though.
- This is actually funny.
- [Gary] Okay, first, when is it?
Keep going, Ill.
Hannah?
Hannah, I don't care.
- Your wifi's like not--
- My wifi's fucking badass,
don't try to diss on the wifi.
Keep fucking going.
- [Illmind] I'm on 3G,
I'm not even on Wifi.
- [Gary] Nik's first photo ever
is with LeBron James (laughs).
- [Hannah] Stop.
- [Nik] It's me and LeBron.
- [Gary] December 28th, 2012.
- That was worth creating an account.
- [Nik] Yeah.
- [Hannah] You look
like such a little baby.
- That's crazy bro.
- [Nik] I created the account
for that picture, I think.
- [Illmind] That's insane.
- Oh my God.
- That's unbelievable.
How's you get, what happened?
You were a good player and
they got you in, like what was?
Why do you have this photo?
- That was my first year at
the University of Michigan,
and one of my teammates at Michigan,
who now plays for the Knicks,
his name's Tim Hardaway Jr.
He played with me and his father
worked for the Heat at that time.
And so the Heat were playing
the Pistons in Detroit.
- Keep going Hannah, don't give up.
Don't fucking give up.
Iris, do you wanna help Hannah?
You're a big fan of her work.
Can you please scroll her Instagram?
Iris, can you please
scroll Hannah's Instagram?
- [Hannah] You don't have to
scroll through my Instagram.
I'm not done.
- I'm on 2014 right now.
- I mean, how many posts
have you, Nik, how many posts
have you posted on your Instagram?
It says it's one of the top--
- 623 posts.
- 623, okay.
3,500.
- Yeah, okay, so you're gonna have
to scroll for six times longer.
Nothing too crazy.
We'll be here for a little bit longer.
Ill?
- I'm good, yeah, I'm going.
I'm still going.
- While you guys are doing this,
I want everybody also to go and look at
Oprah's first-ever Instagram photo.
- [Hannah] How are we supposed
to do both at the same time?
- Well, you're not supposed to do that,
but we'll have somebody do that while,
why don't you do that Seth?
We're gonna pull up Oprah,
since we just talked
about her first Instagram photo, as well.
- I love Oprah.
- [Gary] You love her so much, right?
- I really do.
- And her first Instagram
photo should be pretty iconic.
- [Illmind] How's her aura?
- She's powerful.
Honestly, she commands attention.
She speaks with such
authority and vulnerability.
- [Gary] Hannah is talking
and scrolling as we speak.
- It's kind of insane.
- She's doing a no-look scroll.
It's kind of like a no-look pass, Nik.
She's doing no-look (laughs).
- Dre has that same, you know when
certain people walk in a room?
- [Hannah] They just do.
- [Gary] Legends have
aura, that's just real.
- And it's like, they
don't have to say anything.
- I love that song, by the way, Neon Guts.
- [Illmind] Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- I love that song.
- [Illmind] Neon Guts is my shit.
- I have a running list in
my notes of good rap lyrics
that would make a good Instagram caption,
and that's one of them, Neon
Guts and the Colorful Aura.
- [Illmind] Pharrell's a genius, man.
- Hannah, how's your
scrolling coming along?
- [Hannah] I mean, it's going, it's going.
- [Illmind] I'm at 2014.
- Okay, we've got Oprah's first photo.
Let's see what it is.
- [Illmind] This is fun, actually.
- What?
(laughing)
- [Illmind] What is it?
- Are you for real?
- What date is that?
- This is really upsetting.
This is April 25th, 2012.
And Oprah's first photo is of Gary Vee.
- No.
- You know, just trying
to live life out here.
- See?
You knew, you set this up so fucking well.
- What a fucking flex!
Hold on.
- If I had known I was giving you
a fucking lay-up right there.
- [Gary] Lay-ups out here.
Nik's here, I gotta throw a lay-ups.
I gotta throw lay-ups.
Uh, uh.
- That's crazy.
- [Gary] That was fun.
- [Illmind] Fuck.
- [Gary] That was a little fun for me.
- Guys, mine's gonna be so anticlimactic.
It's gonna be.
- Well, I get it.
Well, actually, so far
Nik's was with LeBron.
Oprah's first photo was with me.
(laughing)
Actually, what's my first photo?
It's gonna be ridiculous.
Actually, can you, Tyler can we--
- Oh, I'm actually getting close.
I have a lot.
I probably, how many do you have, Hannah?
- [Hannah] I have
probably more than 3,500.
- When did you join?
What year?
- It was actually New Year's
Eve that I posted my first,
and I think it was New Year's of 2012.
- Nik, what was your
favorite toy as a kid?
While these guys are going through that,
we're gonna go through favorite toy.
Singular, favorite toy as a child.
- Oh you know what it was called?
(laughing)
- [Gary] Yes, I just love your face
how you actually figured it out.
- What was it called, it was a beatbox.
You know those like, "Twist it!
"Pull it!"
And then it was like--
- [Male Voice] Bop It.
- Bop It, that's what it was.
- [Illman] Boppin.
- [Gary] T-rock's on, guys,
T-rock's having a great day.
(laughing)
- [Nik] Yeah, definitely, Bop It.
- Anik, you just came
in here nice and slow.
- I was told to.
- Yeah, we know, I'm glad you're here.
How you doing?
- I forgot about some of these pics.
These are good pics.
- [Gary] You got some good stuff, see?
- Yeah.
- [Gary] You got some recalls.
- It's not every day you go
through your entire feed.
- [Gary] Yes.
- You know what's cool
about Instagram, too?
And especially successful
people, you get to see
where that cut-off point was
of, oh they got money now.
(laughing)
You know what I mean?
- Why, are you wearing
garbage cans on your head?
(laughing)
- I'm still very poor.
Mom's basement.
- Illmind, what about
your favorite toy of all--
- [Illmind] Growing up?
- Yeah, of all time.
- Shit, it must have
been a Star Wars thing,
like a Star Wars toy.
- [Gary] How old are you?
- I'm 35.
- [Gary] Got it.
- Yeah, so some kind of Star--
- [Gary] Return of the Jedi?
- Star Wars was before my time, too.
- I know, was Return of the Jedi your jam?
Were you there for that?
- [Illmind] No.
- What year were you born?
- [Illmind] It was 80,
I don't even remember.
- You do not know your birth year, bro?
- [Hannah] You were born in--
- '82, '82.
- [Hannah] '82, yeah, because
my brother's the same age.
- What the fuck was that?
I've never seen, guys, this
was, forget about me and Oprah,
that was the, I've never seen that before.
I've never seen somebody
struggle so hard, at least
that wasn't in their 90s,
of what year they were born.
Have you gotten to your first photo?
- I'm so close.
I'm so close.
- [Hannah] I feel like I'm close, too.
- Hannah, what is your
favorite all-time toy as a kid?
- I don't know, I don't
think I played with toys.
- [Gary] Really?
- I mean, I played a lot of
video games when I was a kid.
I loved like that, I can't
even believe I'm saying this,
but I loved that terrible
Sega game, Echo the Dolphin.
- Oh, I loved Echo the Dolphin!
- [Gary] That game is terrible.
- It was so bad, but I did love it, too.
I don't know.
- Oh you know, what, I'm
gonna change my answer.
My shit was video games,
I'm a video game--
- I also really loved Sonic the Hedgehog.
- [Gary] Don't fucking
steal Hannah's answer, bro.
- [Illmind] No, that just reminded me.
- You're just stealing her shit.
- [Illmind] Sonic was my shit.
- But I also, I was a dancer,
so my favorite thing were my dance shoes.
- [Illman] Earthworm Jim?
- Yeah, I was kind of the same way.
I was gonna just say basketball
or I loved basketball shoes,
like Jordans growing up, I loved shoes.
- You know I never owned a pair
of Jordans in my entire life
because I hate him with
all my fucking heart?
- [Nik] Why?
- Because I'm a Knicks fan and
any real fucking Knicks fan
hates Michael fucking Jordan.
(clapping)
- But you respect the greatness, though?
- [Gary] Of course.
- Of course, but Patrick
Ewing, by the way,
you didn't ask me who my
favorite sports' person was,
I don't know if that was just a gender?
(laughing)
- When did we do favorite sports?
- You asked Nik who his favorite sports--
- Yeah, I was making it
contextual to his world.
- Well, anyway--
- He's a basketball player.
- Mine was Patrick Ewing
because I'm a Knicks fan.
- [Gary] I love you for that.
- [Illman] Wait was your--
- Patrick Ewing is my
favorite all-time player.
- He's the best.
By the way, I saw Kembe
Mutombo once in a club,
and I tried to take a photo
of him, and guess what--
- And he did the finger?
He did the finger!
No, did Kembe fi--, did the finger?
I almost went (laughing).
- [Hannah] I know you,
yeah, no, no, no, but yes.
- [Nik] No, no, no.
- Guys, get to your fucking first photo!
- [Illmind] I'm almost
there, I have a New York--
- You've been saying "almost" for years.
- [Illmind] I have a New
York Knicks flex moment.
- I like it that Nik had
eight photos on Instagram.
- I have a New York Knicks flex moment.
I wanna, fuck this, I'm doing it.
Anthony Mason's son--
- [Gary] Oh, Anthony Mason Jr.
- So I was at A3C in Atlanta,
and I shared an elevator
with Anthony Mason.
- [Gary] Senior?
- Senior.
And he said that his son is a fan of mine,
listens to my beats.
- [Gary] That's fucking cool.
- Whoa, that's amazing.
- I was like, am I in the
elevator with Ant Mason right now?
- I have also another
little sports situation.
My uncle, Lou, started the Gouchos.
- Oh, I used to play against
Gouchos all the time.
- You did?
- Yeah.
- And did you beat their faces?
- I dropped like 35 on them
one time in Pittsburgh.
- [Gary] Alright, Ill?
- Alright, August 31st, 2011.
It's a picture of, what is it?
What's his name?
- [Gary] Where's mine?
He fucking quit, Tyler, wait a minute.
- [Male Voice] It's 5:04.
- I don't give a fuck if
it's fucking midnight,
I asked you to get to the first photo.
You gave up like two seconds.
- Got mine!
- [Nik] Oh, we got both at the same time.
- I'm so happy everybody
has theirs, but mine
because Tyler, who's supposed to help me
in situations like this literally
just disregarded my request.
I asked nicely.
- [Hannah] What are we looking at here?
- [Illmind] Mine's a picture
of a Harry Potter wand.
It's a Harry Potter wand.
- [Gary] You are a straight nerd.
- [Illmind] I told you I was a nerd.
- [Gary] Five Likes, two comments.
- [Illmind] What'd they say?
What were the comments?
(laughing)
- The comments were "You fucking nerd."
No, I'm just kidding.
Guys, the first comment is,
"Yo, I'm a half Filipino kid
"from Bloomfield who manages, got some."
- [Illmind] Hey, kid,
that's where I'm from.
Swag.
- [Gary] Hannah?
- I told you it was
gonna be anticlimactic.
- Hannah's is 27 Likes, one
comment, January 5th, 2012.
It's fireworks.
- [Hannah] It was from New Year's Eve.
- And the one comment is, "I
hope my first and only wife
"looks something like you
because then I wouldn't have
"problems doing anything it takes
"to keep her happy, kicksagram."
There you go.
All these pervy dudes.
- Whoa.
- That's calm on, thank God, for--
- That's 318 weeks ago.
- [Gary] Just like yesterday.
- This, I should have started with this.
This was the second post.
Me in the studio.
That was the proper one.
- But that's not how it works out.
That's not ever how it works out.
- [Illman] I'm deleting
the Harry Potter one.
- I cannot wait to see
those photos on Twitter.
Guys, remember, what was
the hashtag, #GVinsta?
- [Hannah] #GVfirst--
- Oh no, it's #firstinstaGV?
- No, #GVfirstIG.
- #GVfirstIG, okay, thank you guys.
Which is why you guys got
good grades and I didn't.
- When you look back at the
early days of your Instagram,
I'm like, what was I even up to?
- You were not up to the
things you're up to now.
That's what's up.
- Except for still killing
the nail art game, though.
Let's get real.
- [Gary] Yeah, you were,
that's really good, actually.
- Been on that early.
- [Nik] You were up on that.
- Since the 90s?
- [Hannah] You know.
- Guys, I really appreciate having you on.
Last parting words for the
audience, what do you got to say?
Hannah?
- Last parting words for the audience.
- Anything you want, questions,
statements, inspirations,
demotivations, whatever you roll with.
- I don't know, do what
makes you feel good.
- [Gary] Good, I like that.
Nik?
- Be great, perfect your craft, I think.
For me, that's what motivates me.
Every day I just look at
guys that are the best
in their sport or their profession.
I look at guys like Tom
Brady in the Superbowl.
- Dude, hold on, hold on, hold on.
We don't talk, we don't mention that.
- [Hannah] I knew this was
gonna go there (laughs)
as soon as you just said that.
- [Gary] Dude, our friendship
just took a huge setback.
- I'm so, so sorry.
I'm--
- I'm literally looking at
you with a huge Jets logo
over your head, no, no,
above it, see it right there?
This is my angle.
- [Nik] Oh yeah.
- Know how I talked about
the Jordan thing earlier?
- Yeah.
- Brady's on some more current
feeling shit, you know?
So, no.
Okay, say somebody else.
Pick somebody else.
(laughing)
- I mean, even someone
like Floyd Mayweather.
- [Gary] No, no, I'm just
kidding, I'm kidding, I'm kidding.
- A guy like Floyd Mayweather.
He's just all about perfecting his craft.
He's just obsessed, every day,
whether it's three in the
morning, four in the morning.
He just goes to the gym.
He's like, "I want to be the best ever."
And he's 50 and 0 because of it.
So, be great.
Do what you do.
- [Gary] Love it, Illmind?
- I would say, man,
just try a bunch of shit
until you find something
you're obsessed with doing,
and then just do it everyday.
- Yes, guys, I really appreciate you.
Have a great weekend.
- [Nik] Appreciate you.
- [Hannah] Thank you
so much for having me.
- You got it?
Wait, that was actually
unbelievable timing.
Tyler, you actually did
this perfectly (laughs)
because if you had it earlier,
we wouldn't have had
this incredible moment
on podSessions number four.
I can't wait to see what it is.
Don't say anything, let me see it.
Is it ridiculous?
Oh my God, it's a picture of my daughter.
I'm such a better human than you guys.
See ya!
- Harry Potter wand.
- 204 comments, 512 Likes, each shit guys.
(laughing)
- [Hannah] Hilarious.
(electronic music)